[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le moment de mettre en valeur des
hommes et des femmes qui se donnent
corps et âme pour rendre et pour faire
monter le niveau de la langue française
voilà je vous le dis il de la télévision
française on vous le disait tout à
l'heure la ville à des marseillais a
connu un incendie
et oui heureusement personne n'a été
blessé alors vous le savez quand une
maison prend feu on se dit tout de suite
qu'est ce que je voudrais soulever en
premier des flammes non mais c'est vrai
je pose tous la question
l'argent les bijoux les papiers
d'identité les albums photos ben pour
millas le plus important c'était pas ça
vous allez voir c'est très très touchant
regardez
[Musique]
proto la maison brûle et la façade et
noir il ya plus de vitres y'a plus rien
c'est vraiment le chantage à la hauteur
je suis en larmes parce que moi l acteur
il a survécu
le fait de le retrouver intact et ben ça
me permet de me baiser pour moi c'est un
souvenir je me dis c'est quelque chose
qui m'appartient et c'est quelque chose
que je veux garder
j'ai trop content ça m'a ému alors on
continue avec une épreuve très compliqué
très compliqué dans la bataille des
commandes est bien là pour semer leur
place dans l'émission les candidats
devaient réussir à faire tenir des
briques en équilibre tout en évitant des
obstacles et un seul homme a réussi ce
défi on se dit tous bravo ça y est il
est sauvé sauf qu'il a oublié un truc
important c'est que sa femme devait
aussi réussir le défi est là c'est pas
le même délire
oui mais je vois pas tous ses droits
comprenez m'a pas dit
[Musique]
ou enfin peut enchaîner
boulay boulogne2 l.blanc caire le
ministre de l'éducation raconte partout
qu'il est rassuré par le niveau des
écoliers en français elodie partout
partout partout et bien j'espère que le
ministre n'a pas regardé la télé
française est bien évident toi je vous
conseille de fermer les yeux et vous
boucher les oreilles ça arrive de vous
faire très mal
vous allez voir la pire faute valait
hier rien ça va ça peut le faire et ça
peut marcher
ça veut dire que dans la vie de tous les
jours ça va c'est ça va être comme sur
des rollers bon va découvrir sa caserne
d'ali baba
je veux dire on s'aime pas du tout a
essayé de voter contre moi tu sais
pourquoi à charge de revanche
on devine que vous n'êtes pas très
emballé par cette tenue c'est un peu une
cacophonie
quand je vois ça franchement j'ai mal à
ma france
alors cette lui après avoir fini la
lecture du dernier prix goncourt puisque
ça y est je les termine et tous les
autres n'habitent pas dans le monde
n'avait pas le monde de la même façon
jean paul dubois pas qu'il a dû je me
suis regardé l'émission id voyance pour
vous parler d'une affaire de coeur
ça fait plusieurs jours qu'un homme
appelle parce qu'ils pensent que sa
patronne veut le pechoux ils travaillent
dans ces que de la télé alors
effectivement le mec perçoit des signes
en garder mais je suis pas certain que
ce soit les bons vous allez vous faire
votre analyse autre analyste chez vous
j'ai pas l'impression que il est sur le
bon bah ils regardent vieille adiyiah
d'hésitation ça se tourne autour tout ça
il ya quand je constate qu'elle prend
toujours la même chose et sa fille non
non paul non non je vous dis non tout de
suite quand il en fait dans color que je
perde mon travail parce que nous le
rappelle n'a pas vraiment non mais des
coups de classement sur la tête ça me
fait mal au crâne et sans fil
[Musique]
meetic et quand ils sont pas en tournage
des émissions de télé réalité les
marseillais w9 passons une interview
dans l'émission notre ami magali berda
alors cette fois ci c'est le candidat
kevin des marseillais qui a l'honneur de
participer à l'occasion d'une sortie en
bateau il propose à magali de refaire la
fameuse scène du titanic et le problème
c'est que tous les deux ils ont dû voir
titanic mais en version où mène sous
titré en berbère regardez-vous si kevin
il est temps pour moi de rentrer au port
merci j'en peux plus de cette journée je
suis fatigué je vais aller me changer
voilà et à bientôt à tous pour une
nouvelle incruste
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le che